- So it's really terrific to
be able to welcome everybody
to this event.
This is The Fourth Annual Symposium
on Hybrid Scholarship at Yale University.
We call this event Beyond Boundaries,
this is the fourth year in a row
that this event has been organized
as part of the program of the
Digital Humanities Laboratory
here at Yale University Library,
and the fourth year it's been organized
almost single handedly by Catherine DeRose
whom I hope most of you
in the room have heard of
if not met.
Cathy is in a new role here
in the Digital Humanities Laboratory
serving as the manager for
the Digital Humanities Lab,
and it's really due to her
organization and her vision
that we've been able to do these
fourth year in a row of the
Beyond Boundaries symposium.
And really the move to
this part of the library
because those of you
who've attended before
know that we've been in a lecture hall.
The move to this part of the library
and the connection with the Franke Family
Digital Humanities Lab to my right
is symbolic of a bigger renovation
a bigger shift in the library physically
and a really exciting
suite of new services
that we are offering
in the new Franke Room.
To support Digital Scholarship,
Hybrid Scholarship and
the Digital Humanities
in a beautiful new room.
Through the generosity
of the Franke Family
in conjunction with
the Goizueta Foundation
we're gonna be holding our Poster Session
at the end of today's
activities in the Franke Room
which I hope those of you in
the room have seen this before
but if you haven't
it's a really terrific opportunity to see
the breadth and depth of projects
that we're highlighting in the Franke Room
right after our round
table discussion today.
As I mentioned this is the fourth year
we've held Beyond Boundaries
and we're doing it in partnership
not only with Yale STEAM,
which is a group that is
dedicated to the intersection of
STEM and the Arts and Humanities
but also this year
in a new effort with Code for Good,
which is a group on campus
that is interested in
the social impact of code and programming.
We're really excited to be
able to partner with these two
student focused organizations
to bring you Beyond Boundaries.
We're gonna just go right
in to our lighting talks,
I think we have seven folks
who are going to be able to
give us some terrific insight
into things they've been working on.
These include efforts by undergraduates
and graduate students
and so without further ado
I would like to ask Zen to come up
and to talk to us about
Organizing without Oppression
Building Democracies in the 21st Century.
Zen.
(applause)
- Good afternoon,
it's an honor to be here today.
My name is Zen Tang
and I'm a senior in the Stats
and Data Science Department.
So I like to start by asking a question.
How many of you guys have
heard of the singularity?
I see a lot of hands going up.
And you might think of it as
a point where machine intelligence
and artificial intelligence kind of
rapidly improves
and maybe surpasses human intelligence.
You might think of it as a syntheses of
perhaps human and machine
where we work in integrative systems.
You might think of it
as a robot apocalypse
(laughter)
where the machine just becomes
really good at making paperclips.
And (laughs) something
that I think scares,
at least me,
and I'm sure maybe some of you
is that there's this question of,
"How do we make sure that
the systems we built,
actually do what we really want them to?"
Now what we say we want them to,
but what we really mean.
How can machines that
are made out of silicon
and programming languages
ever comprehend what it means to feel?
What it means
what we value in life?
How we live and act?
And how we conduct ourselves
with our fellow humans.
I think one problem here
is the issue of trust.
Part of these issues are,
do we have faith that
the machine that we built
will in fact satisfy these specifications?
As computer scientist,
we might like to have
some kind of guarantee,
we might wanna say,
"Okay, Here are certain criteria
that our systems will satisfy."
We might wanna prove that for example,
these systems can't go havoc.
They can't for example,
turn into a totalitarian regime.
Now,
some of the questions involved here
might seem pretty new.
For example autonomous car systems
have been around only
for a couple of time.
But as a matter of fact,
these questions are actually really old.
They've been some of the questions
that we've been thinking
about for hundreds
if not thousands of years.
We've actually had super-intelligences
for almost as long as
we've had civilization.
Now what do these super-intelligent
systems look like?
I mean I don't see any AI here.
They look like governments,
systems of law.
Maybe economies,
these organization of people and machines
can do things that none of us ever could.
They integrate terabytes if not exabytes
of information everyday,
shape the flow of
information and resources
across the whole world
and sometimes do things
that we wouldn't really want
or expect from our systems.
Things like war, famine
and other things.
Now the people who ask
these kinds of questions,
I'm actually sorry for the yellow,
that might be hard to read.
(chuckles)
So people asks these kind of questions
are generally regarded perhaps
as political theorist,
economist,
philosophers,
artists and writers.
These questions are,
"Do these systems actually
act from my best interest?
Do they act in the best
interest of society?"
and if we're in charge of
designing these systems
as a society,
"How do we design them
so that they have the
properties that we want?"
How do we design them so that they ensure
for example freedom and
equality for everyone?
How do we design these systems
so that they are safeguarded in place,
so that if these systems ever do fail
we have some insurance that
they won't fail terribly.
Things that the founding
fathers we're doing
when they founded America
when they wrote down the constitution.
Things that people do
when they talk about checks and balances.
Things like taxation or social goods.
Now as part of this talk
I would like to share with you
a vision for our democracy,
and how this one apply to us today.
A lot of democratic theorist think
that democracy in its
current form is not fixed.
Democracy is in fact malleable
is subject to change
and a lot of different systems
it might not even look like
what we think of democracy
as we think of it today.
For example,
how many of you think that voting is
absolutely essential to democracy?
How many of you think that deliberation
is absolutely essential?
Can we have one without the other?
Possibly not.
Is one more important than the other?
Can we have different forms of voting?
And these are questions that
a lot of people have explored
in recent years but also in years past.
And this kind of comes out a time where
democracy is kind of hit
by seemingly recent forces.
For example the rise of fake news,
political non-participation
and these criticisms of
democracy are something
that we have to think about
both in terms of
as citizens,
what they mean to us
but also in terms of system designers.
How do we design
new systems so that these
issues can be perhaps mitigated?
I'd like to share with you
a few ideas that a lot of
really cool people have had.
For example, one of the professors
in the Political Science
Department here Hélène Landemore
has proposed an idea of open democracy
which is kind of taking from
the Harbermassian point of view
where you have systems
of deliberate discourse
there are kind of centered around
exchanging ideas between people.
So for example,
you might elect a randomly
selected body of citizens
and those citizens could
deliberate in the best interest
of all citizens
and if they were a random sample
perhaps they would kind
of encapsulate the kind of
interest that people in general have.
You might also think about for example,
systems like liquid democracy
where you would give your vote perhaps,
to someone that you trust,
so instead of everyone voting
for a State Representative,
voting for President.
You just give your vote to someone
and they could vote on your
behalf on certain issues,
you might also think about
ideas about context
and what kind of forums we
might need for democracy.
For example,
would Facebook be a good forum
to discuss certain issues?
And here we found that
Facebook has a lot of
interesting things with it.
And so with technology comes
a certain responsibility
but also a certain opportunity.
So I'd like to share with you some ideas
for bringing these kinds
of theories into practice.
And giving us a sense of
where do we go from here?
And how do humans and technology interact
to form government systems?
So a lot of experiments on democracy
have been smaller scale.
They've revolved around
citizen participation
very specific issues and
a lot of
the process of government
that we have today
are actually really
effective at what they do.
For example, think of
the City of New Haven
or the United States
we have the kind of balance
a lot of different issues.
So one proposal is to test,
new ideas of democracy
by having an online virtual platform.
And this platform would
actually kind of abstract
over core fundamental
identities like people and votes
and give you a set of primitives
on which to build new democracy.
So one experiment that I've
been kind of working on
is kind of gathering a set of people to
kind of build the first version of this
democratic infrastructure.
In which you would have a layer
for the force of foundation
for building new kinds of assemblies.
A different forms of referenda,
different forms of voting
and making that available to researchers
to people in the communities,
to kind of figure out
where that kind of technology would fit
and how it would work in
our existing government.
So our idea is to focus on
smaller scale municipal governments
just because its easier
to work with people
in a local context
and towns are also kind of big enough
so that
you could have interesting
democratic experiments.
And this is kind of the
starting phases of this research
but we're kind of thinking about
you know kind of expanding
it to more people
getting more people
involved in thinking about
some of these issues
like what kind of value should we kind of
think about as we build out these systems.
And yeah do we have any questions?
- That's actually I wanna thank Zen
for being our first speaker
and we're actually going to hold questions
for the poster session in the next room,
because I know that folks are
all gonna have interesting
interactions with our speakers
but thank you so much for going first.
(applause)
- While continuing the theme of
Other Ways of Organization,
we have a talk next by Frances Fagan
on Utilitarian Utopias:
Public Libraries as Key Policy
Partners for Integration and
Skills Training Programs.
Let's see if I can find it here.
- I don't know how to use this so.
Do I just,
okay.
Thank you all for coming,
thank you.
I would especially like to thank the
Franke Family Digital Humanities Lab Staff
for their ongoing support
and guidance in our research.
I feel like the field
of Digital Humanities
is particularly important today,
we're experience what has been called
a fourth Industrial Revolution
which is marked by dramatic transformation
in both the technologies
that impact our working lives
and the ethnographic changes
that are reshaping our communities.
And the visualization tools
that Digital Humanities provides
allow us to asses and share
these changes with others
as we will see in the conversations today
and the posters that
will be presented later.
So I'm Frances Fagan
I'm a political science
student here at Yale University
and my interest lie in
Social Integration and Labor Policy,
particularly how programs
related to social integration
and skills training are
coordinated and implemented
at the local and municipal level.
And it's convenient that
we are in a library today
because I am fascinated
by these institutions.
So here this image allows us to see
all of Connecticut's public libraries
and because of their branch systems,
public libraries frequently have
built-in network characteristics
which allow for coordinated programming
and the sharing of best practices.
So bringing us into New Haven,
this compact image
taken from the New Haven
free public library's website
shows us that there are five
public libraries in the city
and a book mobile.
It also allows us to look at
user trends for the library
and their services in 2018.
And I'm not sure what your perceptions
of public libraries are
but they have been drastically changing.
So they are adapting their services
in programming to meet
the very demands posed
by changes in social
demographic and labor needs.
The books are still popular,
as we can see in this infographic,
there is a constant and
steady increase in WiFi usage
and program attendance,
and these programs range from
story times for new parents
to coding courses for children
to resume workshops and more.
And these trends and programs
are consistent across
developed nations as well.
And I can share from France, the UK
ask me questions about libraries please.
And here we see a selection
of digital courses offered
for free on a monthly
basis right down the street
at Ives Public Library.
A key service offered by public libraries
is digital literacy,
defined by the American
Library Association
as a skill that quote,
"Enables the individual to
recognize when information
is needed and gives them the ability to
locate, evaluate and use that
information more effectively."
It's not enough to simply have access
to a smartphone or a computer.
In order to stay in a
truly democratic society
all members must be able to navigate
increasingly complex technologies
much as we are doing in this symposium
on Digital Humanities today right?
Examples of Digital Humanity
Digital Literacy here range
from free classes on how to
asses and analyze everyday information,
like the infographics in these PowerPoints
to establishing professional
networks through LinkedIn.
This variety of free
training is impressive
yet if we look at the relationship
between government agencies
and public libraries networks
we see a lack of coordination.
This is Connecticut's 2-1-1,
which is the state site
that is intended to serve
as a one stop portal
linking users to essential
services throughout the state.
Yet when I enter job
training formats in New Haven
only one option came up
and as we can see
it's a Pre-employment
Background Check site.
Related searches linked to agencies
which often had barriers to entry
including age, income and veteran status.
The lack of coordination
between government agencies
working with integration and labor policy
in relevant public library programming
is not unique to the United States.
Although both the European
Commission and OECD
stress the urgent need to provide
basic educational programming
and digital literacy training
throughout the United States
their policy prescriptions rarely if ever
mention public library
networks as potential partners.
And if there are any library
librarians in the room
you know how extensive these networks are.
All right so in addition to these
more targeted digital literacy programming
there are countless opportunities
to engage in diverse
social and cultural events
in public libraries.
Such encounters can strengthen
community relationships
in what can be politically and
economically fraught times.
Here we see examples of
some of these programs
that libraries in New Haven
as well as an image of the newly remodeled
Ives Squared Space were
among other cool events.
Entrepreneurs can get
advice on their start-ups
from external partners
and residential fellas.
Earlier today in fact
there was a meetup of game developers
where participants from
all ages and skill levels
came together to share
advice and get support.
I would definitely recommend
if you hadn't been to Ives Square
or have been in to the
New Haven Public Library
since they renovated
to go and check it out.
So I conclude by pulling back
to this overview of
Public Library Networks
on the state level
and I ask that we reconsider
not only the density of these institutions
but also the reach of their
extended networks of patrons,
government agencies and
external partnerships.
How might these connections better serve
the needs of contemporary societies?
And perhaps more importantly
what is your public
library up to right now?
Thanks you so much
I look forward to learning about
Digital Humanities research with you
and to answering any
questions that you might have.
Thank you
(applause)
- Thanks so much to Frances for that
and I'd like to call up for
our next speaker Keniel Yao
who's gonna speak about
Virtual Politics: A Case Study of Reddit.
Great thank you so much
it's such a pleasure to
be with you guys today
and I'm really excited about the work
and that Beyond Boundaries does.
Specifically in my own interest
as a statistics student
whose first love
intellectual love really was anthropology.
I think there are increasing
worlds of social research which
necessitate and demand
a data science approach
and today's research
that I'll be presenting
from my senior thesis
lent itself today as well.
The idea I see data science
and its section of anthropology is this,
specifically that when we're
looking at online lives,
how do we listen to data?
Well it's specifically with statistics
and it suits political life online
especially on word platforms like Reddit
specifically because users are anonymous
and they age geographical.
And so those are approaches and words that
aren't often associated with
ethnographic research where
you're necessarily part of
the community in a space
with people who have names.
And so statistics seem
to be a much more natural
lends itself more naturally to this
The research I'll be presenting on today,
is really focusing on this question,
what does a like mean?
What is a good political comment?
And so this research focuses
on the politics subreddit,
which is a sub community within Reddit
focused on U.S. politics
analyze this data from 2008 to 2018
just for a sense of scale on this data
there's about a terabyte worth
across which is all stored
every single post and comment on Reddit
is stored online on Google Cloud
and is extremely accessible.
Cool
Let's see so it's interesting
because I feel like
a lot of social research
focuses on Facebook and Twitter
and any of these don't seem to
lend themselves as easily to
statistical research because
there's a lot of privacy concerns.
Whereas Reddit is
inherently a public website.
It's known as the front
page of the internet
and surprisingly for a lot of people,
I don't think they know that
this was actually the third
most clicked upon website
in 2018.
Just after Google and after Facebook,
after Google and after YouTube
so before Twitter and Facebook.
Additionally in terms of engagement
based on its population of users
there are more clicks on
more clicks on Reddit per
user than any other site.
So in terms of the richness of engagement
and the richness of data
Reddit really seems to
be a promising tool.
But there's something special about
the politics sub community on Reddit
specifically that with Reddit
each subreddit has its own set of rules.
And so here,
the unique thing about politics is that
users are only allowed
to post news articles.
Specifically when they post
the headline must be identical
to the news article website
and content must be a
link to the news article.
Which means that users
can't impose anything else
and interpretation and
political commentary
can only occur in the comments.
It's really interesting to
look at the distribution
of some of the articles here.
I apologize for the lack
of labeling on the y-axis.
But what that means is
I use the topic model to assess
all of the news headlines
that had been posted on Reddit
from 2008 to 2018
and group them using topic modeling
and then using a walk
trap clustering algorithm
into six main themes.
So the first one reflects foreign policy.
It's really interesting that like
It's kind of stagnant until after 2016
what actually happens is that Trump
gets associated with a
lot of foreign policy
because of the Nuland Investigation
and because of Russia.
And so those topics
actually changed their meaning after 2016.
The graph number two
indicates popular issues
which remains relatively
static across all time,
the increase is just an increase
in population of Reddit.
Let's see number three is election issues
which of course rise up in 2012 and 2016
but particularly after 2016.
The bump in 2016 with number four
actually indicates campaign corruption.
Which shows it bubbles up in 2016
and dies down again.
And number five talked
about economic policy
which is pretty stagnant overall.
And so there's really
cool topic modeling things
that you can do with the whole sub Reddit
and a lot of really interesting
topics come out as well.
So you see the Keystone
pipeline becoming its own topic,
you see "Fire and Fury"
becoming its own topic,
Nuland investigation becoming
its own topic as well.
It's a really really clean dataset.
So the key question coming across,
here are particularly
interesting rules that
the moderators have placed
but they can't enforce
is that they want people users on politics
to vote basically like or dislike comments
based on the quality
and not on the opinion of the comment.
You can't enforce it
because likes are anonymous
and because there's ton of them right.
And so it's interesting to see
what actually happens.
Which is the focus of this talk.
This is an example of a post,
one of the most popular posts of all time
which is Donald Trump
becoming president from AP
and the first comment says,
"4 Dem Faithless electors from
WA: 3 Powell 1 Spotted Eagle"
what's interesting about
Reddit again is that
there is no personalization of feeds.
You can subscribe to different communities
but within a community
everyone sees exactly the
same thing in the same order.
Both post wise and comment wise
and these are related
this order is determined by the popularity
which is likes and the downvotes
of each comment.
And so here we can,
if you're interested you can transfer
every single post into
a tree-like structure
where because you can
have comments comments
to comments et cetera
you can build out what
long comment chains are
and how users are inter-related.
But here's the experiment,
if we're thinking about
what makes a comment successful
or what makes people
like a certain comment.
I framed it in terms of this hypothesis,
running a classifier to see where a model
using just generic
generic variable so for example,
how popular the post was,
where it came from news article,
and when it was posted.
I'm comparing that with
specific language features,
which one is more predictive.
The idea is that
if language features can
actually help prediction
we can also detect which
language specifically
which language feature actually
lead to a comment being
associated with a higher
higher score or a lower score.
And so I run this with logistic regression
basically what that happens
is its classifying comments
into either popular comments
or not popular comments.
Where popular comments is defined
as ones who make the top three
the top three most liked comments
off all time on that post.
If you're interested,
the language features
comes from a program called
LIWC or Linguistic Inquiry and Word Count
which is a state of the art psychometric
language analysis tool.
It labels
comment or any sort of text
with positive and negative emotions
but also things like
how analytical it is
how much power is used
authenticity, emotional tone.
So these are a lot of interesting
and rich in variable coming
from the psychological
literature that we can
easily label our text with.
I analyze my data on
2012, 2016, and 2018 data
but just here are some
of the brief results.
You'd expect 50% to be like
just a random prediction
of whether a comment is successful enough
and we achieve about a 70% accuracy
with both the baseline
and with the language feature model.
There's no significant
difference between the baseline
and the language feature model.
Precision and recall what that means,
precision is
if I label a comment as
being in the top three
how many of them are
truly in the top three.
And we get about 2/3 accuracy on that
and recall is of all of
the top three comments
how many of do I actually
pick up as correct.
And I get about an 80% accuracy on that.
And so it performs much better than chance
but there's a few more
parameters that we can tweak
that I'll do later on
that are interesting.
In terms of predictive models
here are some of the language features
that the model picks up on.
And so we see that comments
which are analytical
and emotional both tend to lend themselves
towards high popularity.
The contrast there is interesting
but then we can also look at
more sophisticated words
words with longer words
words in dictionaries
and things using numbers
are also more predictive
overcoming being successful.
Interestingly using
more generic adjectives
and using informal speech
associates itself with
not being successful.
Just for those of you who are
interested in Topic Modeling,
this is the next kind
of step in the process
which is if we associated each post
and article with a theme or a topic
then after that
we can really go and see
how language features
vary with each topic.
So for example our
post which have to do with economics more
more favorable if
they're more quantitative
whereas if it's more
about political scandals
do they lend themselves
towards more emotion.
And so that's possible
with this next model that
I'm gonna explore later on.
But yeah thank you for
listening good talk.
(applause)
- Thanks so much to Keniel for that,
and I would like to invite Lis
I'm sorry Tyler Lutz,
who's going to be speaking to us on
Science in Fiction: Modern
Physics as Mirror and Muse.
- Thank you,
in conjectures on World Literature
Franco Moretti articulates
a conception of literature
as a composite product
of endogenous phylogenetic
literary developments
of a given language or tradition
and waves of exogenous foreign forms
that continually buff
it and modulate them.
To read world literature
in Moretti's account
is to read with a sufficient
distance from the text
that these global waves
developments like the novel
or stream of consciousness
come into focus.
Preempting the criticism
that any such world
literary critical project
might undermine the coherence
of national literatures,
Moretti owns that quote,
"There is no other justification
for the study of World
Literature but this,
to be a thorn on the side.
A permanent intellectual challenged
to national literatures."
My project takes,
as its original motive the question,
what is world literature's
thorn in the side?
Or to put it in other words,
why stop at planetary boundaries?
The dizzying expanses
of intergalactic space,
the humming nonsense propounded
at inscrutably small scales
and the coordinated chaos
of global climactic formations
are all as much sites
of cultural production
as any national literature.
All domains of humans experience
that we each partake in.
Where do they fit in Moretti's tidy scheme
of interconnected
ethnolinguistic polities.
Quite long in Richard
Jean So's re-stylization
of Moretti's global
waves as turbulent flow
takes a crucial step towards highlighting
that the very figure
under girding Moretti's
world literature is itself
is a borrowed foreign form.
These are our meso scale
eddies in the ocean
compiled by NASA.
It's only through the
combined cultural production
of interwoven networks
not only of economic historians
that Moretti highlights
but also cartographers,
archeologists, astronauts
and planetary scientists of all stripes
that we can even begin to visualize
the patterns of global circulation
that are preconditioned
for world literature
and not only our world
and national literatures
but two nodes and a vast assemblage
of interlinked intellectual projects
that also becomes difficult to describe
any kind of hierarchy to them.
The closer we look
even at ostensibly hyper local forms,
let's zoom in on one of these waves,
the more we realize
that the local materials
that Moretti's imagining are themselves
subject to cycles of global circulation.
This is an artwork by Chris Jordan
made up of 2.4 million pieces of plastic
that's equivalent to the amount of plastic
that we put in the ocean every hour.
You can argue that this is a
bit of a contrived example.
But let me remind you that
the very English language
that I'm using right now
is nothing more than a accreted flotsam
of many different languages.
So I wanna take this very
seriously as a model of
for literature itself
and if you'll squint at it
just a little bit,
we can actually see something
that looks a lot like literature.
This is
to borrow from Keniel's Topic Modeling,
this is a topic model of
a corpus of fictional text
taken from haughty trust,
this represents
1920 to 1922.
What we're seeing here every bubble
represents a cluster of words
there are groups here
according to their likely
the likelihood of their
co-occurrence in different texts
within the corpus.
And we can see some kind of
recognizable features here.
Here one of these topics
looks like a kind of
courtly fiction upon king, thou, shall
this might somethin be more like a
western, camps trail
there's some rivers,
some Indians
and here's a gender domestics based.
It's not entirely
obvious what these topics
are supposed to represent though
can we call them genres?
Are they somehow micro discourses?
Little subsets of the language?
What I wanna argue is that
what this topic model is showing us
actually is literature resolved
very literally
into its constitutive hermeneutic circles,
domains in which form and materials
are mutually co-determining.
In other words,
the closer we look at world literature
the closer we find
that we end up right
back where we started.
That these turbulent eddies,
I'm thinking of World
Literature as a kind of
fractal pattern.
There's a subset of these
eddies that I might actually
somewhat qualified to
talk about as a physicist.
Words like this entropy.
As a word,
entropy was invented in
1980 by Clausius in Germany,
I'm playing with two
different spellings here
to account for the
difference in the languages.
It gets reinvented in the 1950 in a
by Shannon in a information
theoretic context.
And ever since then its kind of been
percolating in to these
different national literatures.
But true to my argument I think
I wanna think of entropy
as more than just a word.
Through the magic of the
Second Law of Thermodynamics
it contains within it
an entire narrative in miniature,
it goes like this,
"Stuff breaks".
We can even think of
entropy as designating
a kind of micro-genre.
What I hope to do with my work
is to contribute a small
amount to the project
the we might as well
call Cosmic Literature,
by investigating how physics
as a collection of words and stories
that are continually folding
back into each other.
How that physics both
informs and is shaped
by the material constituents
and formal determinance of literature.
One place to start is to disaggregate,
I'm gonna take the English literatures
in the bottom two rows here
and just aggregate them by genre.
Here's a time series of how
entropy shows up in my corpus.
This is not something
I would have expected.
Apparently poets are a lot
more interested in entropy
than our dramatists and fiction writers.
If we poke around a bit more
we can find other words
that show a similar shape.
Here's centrifugal.
Centripetal also has a similar shape.
So does disorder,
and we can go on and on like this.
Chaos
seems to be something that
poetry is very interested in.
I wanna argue that's a mistake though,
I don't either want to say that poetry
is somehow an inherently chaotic
disordered dizzying medium
nor do I wanna say that physics
has somehow been pushing it
in that direction.
My working hypothesis is that
both poetic and natural
scientific depictions
of things like disorder
and chaos
form a closed loop,
each ramifying each other
through a diversity of different channels.
Just so you don't go away thinking
poetry is the only one
getting on the action here,
here's a similar shape
different word
but now actually drama
seems a lot more interested in quantum
than either poetry or fiction.
Likewise with galaxy.
I don't know what to
say about these things,
I don't know how to interpret them,
what I do as a scientist I want to
cast a certain amount of shade on them
these are averages
of course averages we know are
affected by extreme events.
What we really want to do
is take a time slice in these
and ask ourselves
for every point on here
what is the distribution of texts,
the average of which is shown here.
So here I've done that for you,
I'm looking at a different word now,
this is temperature in Fiction
in the same time period,
the x-axis here is plotting
the normalized word occurrence
in the text, the word frequency
and the y-axis is showing
how many texts
talk about temperature at that frequency.
This is a log-log plot,
and it looks quite a lot like a power law
that's super cool.
Again I don't know what this means
I also know it's not
tremendously surprising,
power law show up all over
computational linguistics,
but it's useful for something
by measuring the slope of this line
we get the exponent and the power law.
In other words we get
in a certain sense how
how quickly interest in
these words falls off
as the function of the corpus.
We can do this for
different words as well,
here I'm looking at the word infinite
you can try in poetry, drama and fiction
and of course we can do this through time.
These are no longer fits now,
now my power law hypothesis
is falling apart.
Maybe it might work for poetry,
for drama it's a bit more complicated
but that in itself is
an interesting point.
As a physicist you might wanna call this
something like a power spectrum
and it's interesting to ask,
where do words enter these genres?
Are they coming in
are they just percolating
in through general usage?
And in which case we might
expect something like this,
the fictional case.
Where they're showing up
in the general language
and there's showing up into texts
in a more concentrated fashion.
Or do they show up maybe already
like in the drama case here,
do they just pop in as concentrated bursts
that then flatten out as time goes on.
So that's just the snapshot
of some of the question
that I'm interested in.
Thank you for your attention,
I'm very eager to hear your thoughts.
(applause)
- Thanks so much to Tyler
and could now invite
Lisa up to speak about
Lived Experience as a
Theory of Innovation.
(light applause)
- Hi everyone I'm Lisa,
a junior studying Economics
and I'm also in the Human Rights Program.
And this year I've been
working at TSAI CITY
as a part of the Knowledge
Equity Team to study
some questions that I wanna
present to you here today.
So to start off with,
this is Ikea's refugee shelter
and it was designed at the
height of the refugee crisis
bringing together Ikea's approach
of easy construction and easy assembly
to the massive need of for housing
for the millions of refugees
coming from the Syrian Civil War
and other global conflicts.
So naturally this shelter
won numerous awards
it was praised for being easy to assemble
with no tools necessary
for being more durable
for being stab-proof and more.
Yet when the refugee shelter
was actually deployed
it became quickly apparent
that it was not all that
it was talked up to be.
So some of the complaints
about the shelter.
Meager, limited,
lack of use of local materials,
no insulation,
lack of natural light.
How can it be that a shelter that won
so many awards for changing people's lives
actually had all these issues
and I'm sure that the
designers did their research
but it's clear to me
that a true understanding
of the whole spectrum of local needs
was not at the center of this design.
So why then would this refugee shelter
receive so many awards
when a refugee shelter like this one
crafted ingeniously out
of scavenged materials
by refugees themselves is not applauded
as similarly innovative.
Why is it that innovation that derives
from lived experience
from actually being a refugee
is not receiving awards?
Why is it that learned
expertise has a monopoly,
that learned expertise
is the only expertise
and that professionals
are the only experts?
Naturally this is hardly limited
to the international development space.
I think too often
especially in the social sector,
those in power do not
have lived experience
with the issues at worked hand.
And so I wanna study why is that?
In this semester,
as part of the Knowledge
Equity initiative at TSAI CITY,
I've been studying some of
the philosophy behind AI
to see what it can reveal
about the nature of knowledge
and specifically I've used AI as a foil
to study how human brains
value lived experience.
So first AI naturally
is intelligence exhibited by a computer
as opposed to a human or a living being,
and obviously AI does not have to be
oriented around human intelligence
or replicating human intelligence
but that's the approach I'm taking.
So fundamentally there
are two components of AI,
data and algorithms.
We can think about data as a noun
and algorithms as a verb.
Data represents characteristics
within our world
from personal data which
are markers of our lives
to group data to machine based data.
Algorithms are the mechanisms
by which these characteristics
are transformed
into something useful.
And more often than not
that's something useful as a decision
but it can also be patterns
that help make decisions
and heuristics as well.
For us as humans
we might think of
algorithms within our brains
as wisdom or knowledge.
One of the biggest debates
in artificial intelligence
is algorithms versus data,
which is more important for AI?
Well we might see better algorithms
as better reasoning skills
and better critical thinking skills,
and for humans the equivalent of more data
might be more conversations had
or more experiences.
Of course these two
are intimately related.
Having more conversation for example,
leads not only to broader
pool of data points
in which our brains can draw upon
but also might improve our
critical thinking skills.
But it is also important to point out
that data and algorithms
are not the same thing.
A lack of good data is not
going to be fully compensated by
a good algorithm
and a plethora of data
will not compensate for
a poor algorithm.
So another question to think about
is whether more data is always
gonna produce better decisions
and that's not necessarily true
more data can add noise.
But what is true
and I'm quoting the core data
science team had here is that
"Better data is always better."
So data that is related to the
issue that we are studying.
So given this framework,
where does lived experience fit in?
Well we can think of lived experience
as having characteristics
of both data and algorithms.
It's not data represented in numbers
which is how many of us are
used to thinking of data
but its data as a record
of our experiences.
And lived experience
as data is better data
because it's related to the
issues that we are studying.
Lived experiences are also like algorithms
in that in influences the lens
through which we process information.
So given all of this,
I think what the artificial
intelligence model tells us
is that if the output of our brains
is the product at the inputs
and reasoning skills
then the ideas that we
are able to generate
are directly related to
the experiences we've had.
That's learned expertise
will not have the same realm
of possible ideas as lived expertise
and vice versa.
So an example to bring us
back to the refugee shelters,
someone who has experienced
the insecurity of statelessness
is going to have an understanding
of what it means to be a refugee
and what refugee needs are
that is not replicated by someone
who doesn't have that
same lived experience.
And so the creativity
and innovation that lived
experience generates
is fundamentally different from someone
who is a professional in the
international development space
while a Master's Degree in
international development
might provide an algorithm
with which we can think
about in statelessness
and insecurity
that is never going to replace
the lack of true understanding
of what it means to be a refugee
and the innovation that derives
from that lived experience.
What all of this is to say
is that lived experience is innovation
that our realm of possibilities
is fundamentally related to
the experiences that we've had
and it's also not to say
that it's lived expert
experience versus learned experience
but rather that each of us
has a unique combination of
lived and learned experiences
that influence our
ideas and our creativity
we just need to be better
about recognizing this fact.
So then how did out bias against
learned expertise develop
while also based on our own experiences?
For a variety of reasons
the world we live in
values the professional
but this doesn't mean
that lived experience
is fundamentally less useful
it just means that we
have socially constructed
the meaning around lived experience.
So finally I want to conclude
with a hopeful example
of how valuing lived experience
can improve our world
and also see lived experience
as theory of innovation.
So this is Pigeonly a company founded
to facilitate communications
between inmates
and their loved ones.
Obviously family connection
and communication
is a crucial support system
for rebuilding lives after prison
and that was a crucial point recognized
not by someone who has
never been to prison
but by a former prisoner himself.
So Frederick Hutson an inmate
founded this company after
his experience in prison
and used that experience to found
as the root of his innovation.
His understanding of how
communication and prisons work
combined with his learned experience
participating in accelerator
is what allowed this idea to flourish.
So in conclusion,
I think this conference is
all about breaking boundaries
but I also hope how we can build bridges
and see how AI can help
us value lived experience
as a theory of innovation.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Thank so much to Lisa for that
and now I'd like to call
up our final speaker
Mariel will be talking to us about
Generative and Variational Choreography
via Machine Learning.
- So this work started with a question,
can I use my technical background to
extend my choreographic
practice and create new work
that still feels like my own?
Or to quote my hero,
post-modern choreographer Pina Bausch,
"How can I" well she said,
"I didn't want to imitate anybody.
Any movement I knew,
I didn't want to use."
and so to me that means,
how do I get out of my own head
and my own body?
While still remaining in my body
in creating new work using this tool.
And what I would say is,
this not only requires
freshness and novelty.
Because at the extreme
of freshness and novelty
could be abstraction or
something that is not meaningful
or is alienating to an audience.
But its also dangerous to
stay within a comfort zone
of something that feels authentic
because sometimes that
can just be read as trite
or not generalizable to an audience,
so what I'm interested in
is this intersection of freshness novelty
and authenticity.
And in Pina Bausch's case,
I think this often,
there should be a video,
this often creates really
fascinating results
in choreographies.
So what I chose to embark on
is this adventure to
combine machine learning
to generate choreography
in some interesting ways.
I thought that as a scientist
I might have something unique
to contribute to this conversation.
As well as a choreographer talking about
lived experiences and
how this can be useful.
So this is not me alone,
although I started on my own
I quickly found out that collaboration
is one of the best ways
to advance your project
so I'm in the physics department here
as a PhD student in particle physics
and so I've joined up
with my collaborator Chase
who's a post-doc in the
physics department as well,
with Doug who is established here,
as well as my colleague Ilya
who is a dancer and
researcher in his own right.
Some VR/AR artist and some new dancers
who have been thrown in to the mix.
So a really interesting group of people
in the room at once.
My data collection started at the CCAM,
the Center for Collaborative
Arts and Media.
This is in their new motion capture studio
and I've highlighted these
motion capture cameras
within the room there are twenty in total.
And so I suited up
with these very reflective
sensors on my body.
So overall the data set
that I was analyzing
was a series of about 55 points in my body
in three full dimensions
with very few gaps in the data.
At a pretty high frame rate
for a pretty extended period of time.
This is me dancing in the space.
So we didn't throw machine learning
at this problem arbitrarily.
Machine learning has been shown to be a
really effective tool for
understanding very complex
and non-linear data sets.
That was proven back in the 90s
to show that we can use
machine learning to approximate
any continuous and bounded function
within certain limits.
With some caveats to that
but in general
we approach neural networks
because they are this
incredibly powerful tool
for approximating very
complicated functions.
And this is a bummer that
these videos aren't showing,
but
let me see if I can try this one this way.
This is connected to WiFi right?
Okay.
Yeah I don't know what
to do about this but
I can illustrate and describe
but basically I would say that
something that I've also
found interesting about my
exploration of neural networks is that
they are choreographic in themselves,
the training of a neural network involves
directing
your the movement of a
various elements of your
neural network itself
through this landscape
this higher dimensional or
lower dimensional landscape
that represents the error
inherent in your model
at any one point in time.
So by
so by directing our model in its learning
its
Yes! Oh great.
Cool so
this sort of represents this
trajectory through space.
Represents this higher dimensional
or maybe an abstract
representation of my model
at any one point in time.
I'm trying to give it
the right instructions
to get to a minimum of
one of these points.
So you can see that this model
is sort of moving towards a minimum.
So I wanna minimize my
error overall in my model
and so this is it
a sense of choreography
in itself of figuring out
the right ways to direct this model.
And so I wanted to emphasize this
because I already know
of choreographic research
as very rigorous research
in its own right.
So I didn't want to approach this problem
as a sense of elevating choreographic work
through a lens of technology.
So in a sense I'm seeing
this from the perspective as
a deep dive into machine learning research
with an interesting and meaningful dataset
as well as perhaps enhancing
my choreographic research
through an extended body
or an extended choreographic mind.
And I wanna highlight three
areas of this research
that this work has evolved into.
Preservation
Variation
and invention.
By preservation I mean a sort of
physicalized choreographic brain
and for me that has a lot of meaning
that I don't have time to get into.
But I'll sketch out that
to me movement is a part of my identity
and I don't have a strong
way of preserving that
for my own life.
And so this idea of
preserving someone's style
like for me people have often said that
something about my movement
reminds them of my mom
so there's a sense of
what does it mean to preserve a human?
When style and movement is
important to your own identity.
And also for myself to retain
the potential to invent
with my current choreographic body
or maybe future iterations
of my choreographic body
at any point in time.
So I find that very fascinating.
And so this literally can represent
the actual data of
motion capture of myself
improving in the studio
which is compelling in its own right.
But I hope to extend that by also
physicalizing the potential
of my body to choreograph.
So not only a record
but a kind of limitless model
that can constantly generate new work.
Now I wanted to show what that looks like
when the model is not trained very well.
Just to give you guys a sense
that's it's very difficult to
(audience laughs)
to capture a human body moving
it's a complicated problem
and I am not imposing any
constraints into this model
about what a human should look like and so
I hope that gives some context
for some of the exciting results
that we were able to achieve later
where we are able to generate
arbitrarily like sequences of movement
that really do feel
authentically like myself
because it is derived from my own data.
Now not only are we
interested in preservation
we're interested in variation.
So preservation might
be looking only towards
future results.
Variation is rather looking inward
trying to understand something deeper
about what my choreography represents
and so to me that has represented
projecting this complicated
dimensional data set
into a reduced dimensional data set
to understand some basic
features about how it operates.
As a dancer this is also interesting
because to me its stripping the body away
from the choreographic work
and focusing in on some
kind of innate idea
that is not disturbed by the body
and whatever imperfections it might have.
And it also allows me to
explore related movements
to a input datasets that
I've already included
so this is great for a rehearsal studio
this idea of riffing off a
choreographic idea many times.
So this is one example of how
we can look at choreography
in an abstract way.
This is using principal component analysis
and what this does is
this plot shows a bit of
my choreography over time.
But of course it doesn't
look like choreography
I could peer into this model
at various points
so what I've illustrated here
are two points that are separate
in time in the sequences
that have been somehow grouped
together by this model.
You can see that the model
is capturing something
that feels real or intrinsic
without the choreographic idea
something about moving upwards for example
or me crawling on all fours.
So there are some ideas that
are grouped in a meaningful way
We also have some more powerful ways of
reducing the dimensionality
of this data set
PCA is actually a fairly simple
way of looking at data
because it is linear.
Now machine learning gives us non-linear
learning capabilities
so what we ended up using
was we call an auto-encoder
which can represent a lower dimensional
representation of this work
in a non-linear complicated way.
Here are some examples of
this abstract, dimensional
version of my work.
This represents a variation
on a reference sequence A
and so reference sequence B here
is somehow found by this
model to be highly related
but somehow different
and also completely generated in a sense.
So I'll flash some quick
examples variation.
So here what this
represents the red person
is close to real data,
whereas the colorful person is a
generated variation.
What's interesting about this
is that it's able to maintain
a similar sense of rhythm and style
and yet it somehow feels completely fresh
and is giving it's own
perspective on this idea.
So in some cases we see that
it adds spins or rotation
sometimes it removes spins and rotations
or this is my favorite example,
translates a kick into an
upward movement in the arms.
So there's a sense of
upwardness as an idea
translated into a
different part of the body.
And finally invention,
breaking new choreographic ground
the I otherwise didn't have access to
without this technology.
This allows us to explore new areas
of my choreographic latent space.
That I as a human
have not been able to force
myself to access through
whatever gains and choreographic
constraints I want to use.
So here I'm gonna show
some generated sequences
from my choreographic latent space
that the model has constructed for me.
They're quite short so I'll
flash through some of them,
but you can see that
they look like a person
and to me it feels like me,
but they're completely invented.
And finally I would say
this has just been the
start of some of our
play and our research,
there's a lot of data to be scraped
also from the video performances
and so I've shown
examples of this on myself
in a rehearsal studio.
What this allows me to do
is to take choreographers or dancers
who I couldn't put into the
Yale CCAM Motion Capture Studio
and instead look at videos
of their performances
and analyze their movements in that way.
So I can imagine sampling
from a combination
of many choreographers
latent spaces at once.
We're also interested
in translating motion
from between bodies
and also
analyzing duets and partner work
to imagine generating a partner
given an input sequence of a single mover.
And so on and so on,
research doesn't have an end
so thank you.
(applause)
- Well thank you Mariel
and thanks to all of our presenters
if I could just ask for
a round of applause for
Zen, Frances, Amanda, Keniel,
Tyler, Lisa and Mariel.
Thank you so much.